uh joining us now former US ambassador
to Israel David fredman and former State
Department spokesperson Morgan Ortegas
is back with us uh Morgan let me start
with you we had Mike Pompeo on earlier I
know you work very closely with him uh
let's stay on this question of Iran and
their involvement here and you know even
the Iranian revolutionary guard a lot of
the funding a lot of the support and the
actual okaying of the operations both
North and South Lebanon and Gaza uh
coming Direct ly from them um they seem
to be out of the equation when it comes
to paying a price when they seem pretty
responsible well they shouldn't be Sean
you're absolutely right um and in fact
we know that this attack would not have
happened over the weekend if it wasn't
for the funding the training the
equipping the support uh of the Islamic
Republic of Iran uh to Hamas and not
just to Hamas by the way this is Iran's
Playbook around the region throughout
the Middle East they fund their Shia
terror terror proxy groups like
Hezbollah and Le in excuse me Hezbollah
in Lebanon the houthis in Yemen uh the
Shia militia groups in Iraq which have
in the past by the way tried to attack
uh our US Embassy and kill our troops
and in the Trump Administration in which
uh the Ambassador and I served we had a
very clear line with Iran uh Mike Pompeo
let the Iranians know if you touch an
American if any of your proxies do this
if you H an American if you kill an
American we will hold you responsible
just as if you had done it yourself so
the am Administration um Sean is playing
semantics over well it wasn't this $6
billion or that $6 billion the bottom
line is this Administration has not for
enforced the legal sanctions that are on
the books and one thing that we should
watch out for is in just nine days there
is an arms embargo at the UN that's
going to expire one has already expired
a few years ago but there's a specific
Advanced arms embargo against Iran that
covers the suicide drones that covers
ballistic missiles that will expire fire
in nine days Sean and in nine days the
Iranians can sell that can give that
away can put it out on the market uh
with no impunity on the world stage and
that's something that we should be
watching for and something that the
administration should immediately try to
get renewed at the United Nations
Ambassador I've known uh prime minister
Netanyahu oh anywhere between 25 and 30
years and one thing I can tell you uh
this is a man that has moral Clarity
this is a man that will protect his
Nation this is a man that will stop at
nothing to win this War I would imagine
at at his call that holy hell is about
to be Unleashed in the Middle East
probably the likes of which we've not
seen before he has said as much um how
for how would you interpret those
remarks well Sean I think you know we
saw over the last couple of days the
orchestrated and barbaric murder of Jews
the likes of which we haven't seen since
the holoc and I know the Prime Minister
well as do you and I've worked with him
closely for four years and if there's
one overriding mandate that bib
Netanyahu has is to make sure that there
will never be another Holocaust that
that is his that is that is his
fundamental mandate not just to the
state of Israel but to the Jewish people
and and what we saw requires the kind of
response the likes of which Israel has
never undertaken before it will be a
massive overwhelming response until as
is completely obliterated and then you
know remember the head of the snake as
as I think Morgan alluded to the head of
the snake is Iran and I think um you
know whether it's bb or whether it's the
policies that we worked under you know
Donald Trump didn't pay terrorists
that's sort of the simple point he
wouldn't pay uh Iran he imposed massive
sanctions on Iran he eliminated kasum
suani Iran's leading terrorists wouldn't
pay the Palestinian Authority because
they had a program called pay to slay
where they would incentivize
Palestinians to kill Jews the more Jews
they killed the more money they got it
wouldn't fund unra an organization in
the Gaza Strip that taught and
encouraged young Palestinians to hate ju
and to kill them okay if that's the if
that's what they're going to do they're
not gonna get any money and now we're
looking at Iran today it's in a very
different place Iran three years from
now from then is a much wealthier
country you look the number of barrels
of oil they're selling every day it's
gone up dramatically over the last three
years they have a lot of money and
they're using that money to fund mign
activities all over the world and so
when Hamas is done and they will be
obliterated I trust I trust BB he's GNA
get this job done when they're
obliterated will will will this conflict
I only got about 20 seconds left will
this conflict unite the people of Israel
behind the Prime Minister whatever
actions he deems necessary to take it
already has and tens of thousands of
Israelis who were living outside the
country country have flown back into
Israel to join the Army to join the
reserves the country is United like ever
before and Hamas made a huge
miscalculate all right Ambassador thank
you Morgan good to see you thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else